hey everyone I have a really awesome
guest here you guys are all aware of who
he is it is David Pakman how's it going
man good thanks for having me yeah of
course so to start off I thought I'd
start off asking about how bad the Trump
presidency has been not about how it's
been but how bad it's been well it's
been bad I mean I guess it depends on
how you want to sort of slice and dice
it there are the sort of policy
questions we could talk about there is
the side of just how is the u.s.
perceived around the world and kind of
the office of the presidency has that
been bolstered or hurt by the Trump
presidency I would argue the latter for
sure and then in addition to that we're
now starting to see some concerning
economic circumstances increasingly
which which we could also talk about so
it really depends on how you want to
slice and dice it but I have I have a
really hard time finding too much
positive that that can really be said
isn't it really hypocritical that now
they have their their deficit ballooning
so I think it's like almost 800 billion
at this point oh yeah I mean the so
here's the thing they don't care about
the debt and the deficit that's the
thing so the debt and deficit is just a
football and they throw it around when
they campaign they say we will fix the
problem when it's a Democrat in the
White House they say they are the
problem but then as soon as they
actually have decision-making power it
becomes clear they don't care about debt
and deficit and it's like a lot of other
issues where it's just used in order to
either gain votes curry favor work
political deals but they don't actually
care about the debt and deficit and
there's an argument to be made based on
the teachings of modern monetary theory
that we should all kind of rethink how
we even perceive those issues but that's
a separate conversation from whether
they are total hypocrites and they are
right and so what I think a lot of Trump
supporters will talk about is they'll
sort of give Gallup all the unemployment
statistics and things like that how do
you you know what do you what would your
response to that be it depends on the
situation okay so there are certain I
mean Gish Gallup is tough for if you're
really trying to have a productive
conversation and someone decides they're
going to get calop you which for people
who don't know it's basically a debate
tactic where you just throw a whole
bunch of stuff at once conflicting
information disjointed arguments facts
that may or may not be facts but it
doesn't matter and basically you you
make it impossible for your opponent to
really debate in good faith because they
they first have to go be they have to
make the choice to either ignore all the
crazy stuff you said or go back to the
beginning and start refuting one by one
so number one it's really important to
understand that if whoever you're
talking to is determined to get calop
you it's very difficult to actually
interrupt that but the the best strategy
if you actually want to talk about debt
and deficit and someone on the right
starts throwing unemployment numbers at
you or stock market numbers at you or
more black people than ever are working
right whatever whatever the case may be
I would just go back to the hypocrisy to
first see if you can pin them down on
whether or not they think Trump blowing
up the deficit is a problem and try to
focus on that if you can get them to say
okay well yeah that that is a problem
then maybe you can have a conversation
but it's really difficult if someone
doesn't want it to be in good faith
which unfortunately is really common
right now in just about a week now do
you think that the Brett Kavanaugh thing
who do you think is more is more sort of
enthusiastic and more motivated to go
out and vote how do you think the house
is gonna go and how do you think the
Senate is gonna go
I have no special insight into that last
part the polling seems to suggest that
it's still more likely than not that
Democrats take over the house although
some of the polls I've seen show it's
not going to be as clear a victory as
maybe it seemed three months ago Senate
still seems most likely to stay in the
hands of Republicans I think that the
Cavanaugh story will not have a huge
impact based on one poll I saw it seems
to be making Democrats slightly more
enthusiastic than Republicans but it
doesn't seem to be a big net difference
and by and large I mean as predicted
why wouldn't Republicans just force
through the Cavanaugh confirmation if
they predict which is the case that it's
not really going to hurt them come
election time and I think it will be a
very very small factor you've got a lot
of local races that are mostly going to
be dictated by local issues there may be
more of like a referendum on Trump angle
but I just have a hard time imagining
that the Cavanaugh Fiasco is going to
play significantly either way and
looking past the midterms looking
towards the 2020 election I'm curious as
to who who are your ideal candidates for
a 2020 run within the Democratic Party I
couldn't even tell you right now I mean
what I can tell you is that if someone
is going to defeat Donald Trump it's
going to have to be someone who at least
on some level is going to play the game
the way he plays it now that doesn't
mean making fun of disabled reporters
it doesn't mean slamming the families of
deceased military members I'm not saying
literally they have to do the stuff
Trump does but they're going to have to
at least on some level engage with the
type of rhetoric that he does well with
and the type of rhetoric that clearly
resonated with the people that did
support him I don't think that someone
who is perfectly buttoned up and sort of
the picture of total decorum is going to
win
he is going to play his games and he
will crush them and I don't know I don't
have a full list of people on the Left
who are willing to do that right now I
think that you know I was just reading a
piece arguing that even though Michael
avenatti is a horrible character and
representative of so much of what's
wrong with politics that someone like
avenatti
is at least willing to stoop to Trump's
level in the way that he is comfortable
and that some degree of that is going to
be necessary I think there is I actually
think there's a very good chance that
Bernie Sanders runs and I don't know
I've just not been talking about 2020
very much because we've had the midterms
the midterms are almost over so I'll
talk about it a little but I still think
we need to keep our eye on the ball here
I think there's a good chance that
Bernie runs and then we potentially
would get to see well what would it be
like if it was Bernie versus Trump which
I think would be super interesting right
I think I think probably smash out of
the park but did you did you did you see
what Hillary Clinton said about running
in 2020 the other day if I recall
correctly she said I would like to be
president but I don't want to run again
well so yeah she did say that she wanted
to be president but she didn't say she
didn't want to run again she said she
won't even think about it until the
midterms are over but basically but
basically if she were to run again that
would she be able to win against child
oh I don't think so I mean listen it
would be very easy for us to say okay so
she didn't win in 2016 but now people
have seen how bad Trump is so now they'd
go and they'd vote for Hillary I think
that there are like five or six
different ways in which Hillary loses
anyway one would be that it would be
basically just a replay with
interference and everything and you end
up with basically a similar scenario
Hillary winning the popular vote
but losing the electoral vote I think
it's possible that the mere presence of
Hillary throws such a monkey wrench into
the entire thing that it impacts a voter
turnout in a way that favors trump and
states that that are advantageous to him
and there's a bunch of other scenario so
I don't think I don't think Hillary is
the nominee is the path forward for
Democrats but I wanted to go back to the
2016 presidential election now in the
progressive sphere there was sort of a I
want to say like a battle of ideas
between Jimmy Dore and Sam cedar where
did you fall between the two well the
the big thing that I remember
specifically was this issue of how
important Supreme Court picks should be
in considering who it is that we should
vote for and I was on the side of
Supreme Court picks are so important and
impactful for such a long period of time
that that far outweighs the possibility
of saying you know what Trump could be
good because he could cause like a
breakdown of the entire system and allow
a rebuilding a populace rebuilding from
the ground up or those types of
arguments like tear it all down to build
it back up
I didn't buy into that because I
understood the importance of the Supreme
Court and we're seeing that now we're
seeing that now that Trump has had his
Supreme Court picks and we've had a move
drastically to the right on the court
there are really important decisions
that could come up I mean just this week
we found out about the possibility of
the Supreme Court having to adjudicate
whether Donald Trump can end birthright
citizenship by executive order that may
be something the Supreme Court decides
it's just too important to play games
the way it seemed that games were being
played beyond that you know I don't it
was a while ago I don't remember exactly
even what the other disagreements were
so I thought I'd really just want I just
have one statement here that Jimmy said
during his debate with Sam and I wanted
to get your thoughts on it so he said
that the Democrats can filibuster more
than one Supreme Court vacancy for up to
for years what are your thoughts how in
what circumstances did what do you mean
by that like if given what situation in
the House and Senate and how would it be
that they would do that oh so it would
be basically Trump as president I'm not
sure exactly what the circumstances
would have been in Congress but if
you're gonna filibuster you'd have to
have a minority essentially so he was
saying that basically if Trump takes the
presidency and I believe that there were
no predictions that Trump would win the
presidency and the Democrats take the
Senate so I guess it would be that both
both houses of Congress are controlled
by controlled by Republicans yeah well
it didn't happen and it didn't even seem
like it was a realistic possibility so I
mean I guess that that that was just
wrong okay I see as usually so I thought
I I saw recently that you had a little
exchange with Dave Rubin on Twitter now
I wanted to sort of get your thoughts
overall because I know that you did an
interview with Dave Rubin that I thought
was great personally and he essentially
accused you of attempting to gain clicks
you just kind of run us through what
went down okay so my understanding of it
is that when I found out I would be in
LA for politican a few months ago I
guess it was or a couple months ago I
sent him an email and I said hey it
would be great to do this sit down we've
been talking about doing and here are
the dates I'm gonna be there and he said
he was gonna be in Europe with Jordan
Peterson and then I believe it was the
Friday when I was in LA he tweeted that
he was having Tucker Carlson in and I
found that interesting because that was
one of the days I offered to come in
months earlier and he wasn't going to be
available and I guess I don't remember
his response exactly but it was
something along the lines of well I am
leaving tomorrow and I can't do two
interviews today
but you know if you were a decent person
you would have sent a message to me
privately instead of publishing it
publicly I guess it was it was his
argument and and what would your
response to that because I know that you
essentially said that you know you
denied those claims but I don't know it
was just it was interesting to me
because haven't you got it haven't you
been attempting to sort of go like have
a studio interview with him of some
sorts for like a while now like almost
two years I I have but I have not I mean
I was in LA a few months ago but on
vacation I wasn't doing any work stuff
so I mean but in his defense the first
time that I was in LA during the last
year and a half on a work trip was a
couple weeks ago okay so I wanted to
like do you think that he's in any way
trying to evade having you on or do you
think that it just happened the way it
happened I genuinely don't know the
answer to that and I know that I know
that you said that basically you were
you were honestly not really sure what
your status of a sort of whether your
friend friends with him or not after the
interview I mean could you just sort of
give me a breakdown of what happened
after that interview nothing I mean
that's why I'm not sure so I've known
Dave Rubin for a while and we would text
and sometimes talk on the phone and and
that sort of thing and I think it became
less frequent as he had a political
awakening or whatever kind of term you
want to apply to that and then you know
I welcomed him on my show for an hour
and I did an interview that I thought
was completely fair but when things were
said on policy that I didn't agree with
I I pushed back and we have barely been
in touch since then so I mean I guess
the answer is I don't really know what's
going on and do you think that you guys
haven't been in touch because he felt in
some way that I don't know he was I
don't know I guess hurt that you sort of
because I thought I thought it was a
fair interview as well I thought that
you sort of asked him some pretty fair
pointed questions and was he did he not
like find that to to his liking or some
sorts
the case he did not communicate it to me
okay that that's something interesting
so you mentioned his political awakening
I know that you guys have been friends
for a long time and I've seen that some
of your guys's
videos together so you guys
collaborations specifically that of
talking about reza aslan and so i'm
curious what your thoughts are on his
political awakening you know what
happened with him do you think so I
can't really say specifically what makes
someone decide to take certain political
positions there's a huge range of
possibilities one is you you genuinely
just realize that what what your view
was on issues previously is wrong and
you revisit and that's perfectly
reasonable like for example this week I
did a segment on my show where I say
that I have reevaluated my position on
sex offender registries and I'm now
against some and I sort of explain why
and that's totally reasonable that's one
possibility
sometimes people take certain positions
for financial reasons in other words
they come to believe that there will be
a financial benefit or a publicity
benefit to taking one position that is
different than the one you previously
took there can be a change in sort of
like an underlying philosophy that then
you realize oh given that my view on
this has changed I should really have a
different perspective on these
particular issues I don't know what the
answer is with Dave Rubin again because
I've talked to him so little since this
has taken place what I can say is that
as a general concept I don't I think
he's around 40 years old now I don't
know of too many people whose politics
have changed drastically when there are
in their mid to late 30s like I just
don't know I don't know if too many
examples of that I know of lots of
examples of people who Paul whose
politics have changed like when they're
in college for example that's that's a
time
you know short of sort of just having
very similar politics but the party's
changing around you or the alignments
changing around you it seems rare to me
now he might argue that I think he has
that the left abandoned him that like
he's still on the left or something like
that but I I don't I don't know that
that really makes too much sense so I
really can't say I just know that I
don't I've never really met more than a
few people who have had significant
political realignments at that point in
their lives are you are you at all
suspicious that he he changed because of
financial reasons or do you think or do
you get the hunch that it was strictly
genuine like 100 percent genuine I have
no idea and I know that there are videos
online of people saying that there are
funding sources of different kinds that
are sort of conditional on the idea that
certain people are invited or that type
of thing I don't know if they have
strong evidence I really wouldn't be
able to say I also want to ask you about
the interview that you guys did because
I thought that there were a lot I mean I
I want you I just was wondering if you
could sort of expand on certain things
that I saw during that interview because
though I felt like there were so many
points where he was just totally
inconsistent and he didn't really have a
response like I recall you essentially
saying that you know how can you claim
to be a classical liberal which is
essentially all about free markets and
then simultaneously support single-payer
health care and then he goes on to
describe Obamacare and it just becomes
like a complete [ __ ] essentially
yeah I mean really these you know I
think the interview kind of speaks for
itself I don't know that it's totally
fair to him to like riajuu de Kate the
way the interview went right now I think
a lot of these policy questions would
really be questions for him but I think
if you're pointing out that I was having
disagreements with the consistency that
I was perceiving in some of these ideas
during the interview I certainly was and
people could check that out right yeah I
thought you did I thought you did a
great job in there sort of I didn't
think that you
I didn't think that you were in any way
pushing any boundary I just felt like
you were asking for her questions and I
guess he didn't really like that very
much
so here's something else that I wanted
to ask you about I wanted to ask you
about you had a you actually had this
sort of debate with ben shapiro on on
guns and i wanted to sort of get your
thoughts on that debate and just i'm
curious if you are going to do another
debate with them in the future and sort
of why there hasn't been another one
since then because that was actually a
law that was like six years ago right i
don't remember when it was but it was so
long ago that i don't remember how it
went
i see so how did you guys get that set
up
i'm just curious I think I just emailed
him at the time where my producer did
and have you have you attempted to get
in contact with him for another one
before or after that we've been in
contact since then just short emails and
I don't know whether I've actually
invited him back on the program since
and I don't know whether he'd be
interested okay so here was something
you you are a politican and I'm curious
about this because Ben Shapiro was there
and he didn't actually do any debates
and you didn't get to actually do anyone
if he wanted debates with anyone and you
sort of I saw you talk about on one of
your it was like an update video about
political because you had to make a
bunch of them that there were these
people who were sort of chickening out I
mean are there any names that you can
sort of divulge about who backed out Oh
Sam cedar has since gone public with
that and steven crowder backed out of a
debate with him right and was that the
only person who did that outside of
Candis Owens yeah so so I mean as far as
I now have been told Candice had from
what I'm told Candace didn't back out
she was just she had never accepted and
it was communicated to Kyle kolinsky and
to me that we had a debate set with her
and Charlie Kirk the the current story
as they
is that they never had actually accepted
and thus it would be unfair to say they
backed out if that's accurate okay and I
was just curious for Tamil Otakon I was
curious how do you feel about I almost
want to say like the way they set it up
because I don't feel like it's all that
great when there were like almost two
weeks left which is not very long and
people didn't know who they were doing
debates with yeah I think a lot of that
is that they have this really difficult
thing they're trying to do which is to
make the most interesting panels and
debates happen while getting a lot of
situations where people are
conditionally willing to do something if
X or Y other person either is or is not
involved so there's just a ton of
situations where they think they have a
they get conditional agreement for a
four-person panel from three people
person number four then says you know I
really can't be on with person number
two so they say okay we'll replace
person number four with a different
person and then person number one goes
you know I like the original lineup but
I can't really I don't want to appear
with the person you've put in now so
they have this really difficult thing
because they're dealing with a lot of
people with personalities and egos so it
would be great if everything could just
be more fine-tuned way ahead of time but
when you consider people's ego and then
travel changes and the fact that you
know any of the hundred or so or more
people who are participating could have
like an emergency or something like that
I get why it's so complicated but it's
not great from the point of view of the
participants very very tough
I was curious what what was your
experience like at politican for
yourself I know that you were on
multiple panels and other you were on
the this should be the socialist panel
as well as the fake news panel I like if
you just give like sort of a breakdown
of you know your experience at politican
overall it was a good experience I mean
the thing is that there are a lot of
extreme people that go because if you
just think for a second you know
obviously this is
apply to everybody but if you are sort
of willing and interested in spending
money to fly for some people across the
country or people even came from
Australia and it was great to meet fans
from Australia there's nothing wrong
with it but to see people argue about
politics rather than just watching the
videos online or reading articles you're
probably engaged in a way that most
people are not and for some people that
is completely fine and great and sort of
normal but there were a lot of
extremists there who are sort of on the
edges of the political spectrum so that
environment can be a little bit
difficult because you kind of constantly
feel as though there could be some kind
of violent incident at anytime and in
fact with some of my panelists who were
speaking backstage about sort of moments
during different panels where it wasn't
clear whether someone was kind of
getting a little bit out of hand or it
could become potentially even a
dangerous situation but they had a lot
of security and for the most part
managed it pretty well but the
environment is one of high political
tension for sure so I'm curious because
I know that you said on a on a video I
believe it was the bonus show I think
you said that you were you were at the
janitor not the Jencks sorry the Charlie
Kirk and Hasan [ __ ] today and you saw
and you saw that you know the sort of
break out that Charlie Kirk had at Janke
were you there in person for that or did
you see that on video no no I was only
there for about ten minutes in the first
I guess I'd say half hour of the debate
and I had left before the Jenk Charlie
Kirk thing happened so I only saw it on
video later that sort of break out well
I think that Charlie Kirk is trying to
get attention and he knew that if he
immediately stands up and starts yelling
off the stage at genk that it would get
attention and it did the substance of
the debate of the question that was that
was being discussed seemed kind of dumb
to me it started getting into different
people asking others how much
they make and I guess Charlie Kurtz saw
a connection between well if you are
arguing for socialism then your salary
is sort of materially relevant in some
way versus charlie kirk is a capitalist
so however money however much money he
makes is not relevant or open to
criticism it seemed very stupid and it
didn't really go to the merits of any
political ideology so it's interesting
that you bring that up because that's
very true I what I don't understand and
Charlie Kirk is is is very stupid in a
different way than people like ben
shapiro are and if he was trying to do
like this weird connection of like you
know why don't you go live like a
socialist basically saying like why
don't you give up like 95 percent of
your earnings which i just don't
understand and i know that you're you're
very well-versed in political ideology
especially amongst the left so and
especially in things like first of all
hassan pygar is not a socialist right
but it's just it doesn't make sense
because i don't get the connection
between socialism in which the workers
owned industry and giving up 95 percent
of your earnings yeah I mean I think the
most relevant thing is I I know Hassan
sort of and I don't have any reason to
think he's a socialist so I all of a
sudden don't care almost what the debate
is because he's being strong and as a
socialist but I don't it none of it
really seems relevant to me it's sort of
like when people on the right say to
people on the left if you love taxes so
much why don't you just pay more and
it's sort of like well what that that's
not really how you make policy you don't
just say pay more taxes if you want you
need a government that figures out what
is the tax rate that makes sense for the
services we want to have and what
responsibilities should the government
have it's not about just telling people
who think taxes maybe should be hired
should pay more so it's a very silly
argument it's not really an argument in
any way so I wanted to ask you so I saw
I saw that you did a video by Jordan
Peterson and I was curious you took a
different angle in that video I want to
ask
question based on a different angle sort
of about his political statements that
he's made and just the different things
that he said specifically on politics
that he comes into he's sort of he sort
of says some different things but I know
that you've seen them and I'm curious
what your thoughts are well which which
thing are you asking about though well
specifically the he's made these
different political opinions whether it
be about economics and saying you know
he basically made this sort of weird
almost like false equivalency that
there's this far like if you go far left
there is they want equality of of
outcome and then but on the right like
you know it becomes bad or something
like that I don't know exactly what
you're talking about there I mean it
sounds sort of like a blend between
horse-shoe theory maybe and straw
Manning I mean the equality of outcome
thing I can't really think about almost
anyone that actually is advocating for
equality of outcome so I find it to be
mostly a straw man there is a sort of
false debate where the right claims to
be for equality of opportunity and they
say the left is for equality of outcome
when the reality is that the left is
mostly for equality of opportunity and
the right often is for something that's
not actually equality of opportunity so
it's it's become a very false and kind
of toxic debate okay so I want to also
ask you about his his sort of religious
comments now you've made a connection
between him and Deepak Chopra I think
you called him like the Christian Deepak
Chopra essentially and he he's made some
really weird statements like I don't
remember exactly what it was but it was
something to the effect of god is the is
the best best of yourself or something
like that I mean what are your thoughts
on him essentially taking the word God
and basically molding it into almost
like whatever he wants I'm familiar with
one
video where he sort of explode use that
even people who claim to not believe in
God actually do deep down the the one
you're talking about specifically I'm
not aware of offhand but I think it's
all part of a bigger picture where there
is a sort of couching of ideas that are
more relevant to him based on his
specific religious ideology that he's
very good at repackaging into sort of
like common sense
hey everybody should kind of understand
and agree with this and and some of it
relates to semantics as you're pointing
out some of it relates to sort of the
relativism of definitions which he
claims to oppose and yeah I mean I think
that this is a big part of what he does
and it's very effective and he's built a
big following doing it I don't know much
about his self-help material I don't
either but I mean he's got like to clean
your room stuff and I think I remember
reading this article where there was
someone who's a Jordan Peterson fan who
basically said that like his mom told
him to clean his room but he wouldn't do
it but when he started reading Jordan
Peterson he decided to do it I mean what
are your thoughts on because I see I see
Jordan Peterson he'll be with different
people like the coach to the head coach
of the Seattle Seahawks and stuff like
what is the I personally don't
understand what the draw of Jordan
Peterson self-help material is I mean
what are your thoughts on his self-help
material
I think the draw is that even though
it's pretty unremarkable advice that
he's packaged it in a way where it
resonates with particularly men but not
exclusively and he will make that point
particularly men of a certain age who
have sort of identified that they don't
really know what their place in the
world is and they're disaffected in
different ways so it's not it's not
exactly the same way and there
nothing really wrong with the self-help
material per se I mean it's unremarkable
and you can get the same material from a
whole bunch of people he presents it in
a particularly eloquent and appealing
way the danger is that he pretends not
to sort of a spouse political ideology
and not to really be a political figure
and what I expose in my long-form piece
about him is that that's [ __ ] and
that he does espouse political
ideologies and that's where the danger
Falls that if you are a disaffected
young man and you start watching
Peterson and you like the self-help
stuff and then you get into the
political philosophy stuff about all of
the different political issues that
we've been talking about and others you
might start to believe that the way to
the self-help conclusions is exclusively
through his political ideology when they
are two totally and completely different
things and you can arrive at a lot of
the same self-help ideas with totally
different political ideologies and that
is what I see is the most dangerous when
you consider kind of the cult of
personality around Jordan Peterson that
people like the self-help stuff and then
they believe the only road to those to
succeeding in these self-help ideas is
through the political ideology that he
espouses and that's just not true ok so
I see what you're seeing there or I see
what you're saying there sorry I wanted
to ask you about the interview that you
did with Jessica Peterson now it was a
very long interview on the fall of state
and just could you just run me through
what what it was like and just how it
went down because it certainly gave
myself and my audience a bunch of memes
like children of the lie and all that
kind of different stuff and the great
white hope did you just run me through
you know how was it to be to have that
interview and just be which I Seeley
Peterson it was kind of funny I mean I
was curious whether he would be the same
when the cameras are off as he is on
camera and he is so either he's playing
a character all the time or the guy you
see on camera is genuinely the guy he is
it was kind of interesting because a lot
of his producers seem to kind of be fans
of mine and they wanted pictures and it
was just it was all kind of that the
entire scene was was very funny but as
you could probably tell from the
interview I wasn't really taking it very
seriously
but I was kind of respectful in a way
while still kind of getting getting my
point of view there but I saw it more as
an entertainment thing than a
politically valuable thing how did how
did you so the he just contact you out
of nowhere after kicking off the show
and inviting you back on I think when
his producer when he or his producer saw
that I was on the politican schedule
they reached out realizing I would
already be there and invited me to come
on I see are you are you at all
interested in doing that again I mean I
wouldn't do it again tomorrow but I
think if the next time I'm in LA he
wants to have me on I would definitely
consider doing it because the clips do
really well when I reload them I think
the most recent one has almost two
hundred thousand views really really
entertaining but thanks so much for
doing this I really appreciate it do you
have anything anything you want to
finish off with no and thank you for for
having me and my staff sends their
regards they're big fans of the
progressive voice and use and and Kyle
also Kyle kolinsky also said that he
fully endorses me appearing on the
program so that's why I'm here if he had
said it was a bad idea for my career I
couldn't do it I couldn't bring myself
to do it but everybody said you've got
to do it